[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello everyone good morning and welcome
to this dream we are here gamespot live
once again and today stream is sponsored
by black desert which is what we're
going to play today because it just came
out today on the ps4 heck yeah I'm
excited I put this game a bit back on PC
so I'm excited to see how the console
version kind of works over but yeah so
we're gonna start off with you're gonna
you're gonna create a character for us
to play and then I'm going to take over
and just do a whole bunch of yeah get us
back in here cuz I'm sitting on the main
menu for too long yes this game came out
today oh by the way hi I'm precious bin
is here it's me I feel like it's been a
while since you've stream together so
this is actually really fun
it made some characters earlier to mess
around but we're making a new one so
control completely at your mercy
whatever class you want me to play oh I
know
honestly I feel like the classes are so
important
true there's almost like like the wizard
in the which they're both kind of like
magical yeah we were talking about
earlier about the different classes and
how important they are in terms of like
picking them cuz can you change so you
have to make a new character your
classes types here okay after you make I
the one that I played I think the most
is the Ranger I'm not trying to sway you
in any way in that case sounds pretty
cool yeah I saw like some of the
Berserker action in the trailer and I
was like that looks fun cuz I can jump
around with you giant axes and swing
around but uh yeah I'm down for for
whatever you want to make me do all
right sounds good let's see
honestly the wizard already looks pretty
cool like in the little thumbnail well
you get like cool intros really like to
flip onto the screen I do it
do o'night I only say foot because the
Ranger literally does like a backfill
okay I got it see it then she's kind of
just like Oh a nice lips and a very
graceful very graceful honestly men
trailer got me kind of hype for some
phrase okay so I'm changing my mind
once again berserk creative mean weapon
axe sub weapon ornamental not this guy
it looks like a beast - so let's do it
it's very very tall compared to all the
other cares it's it's one of those
setups to where you can't like just make
whatever the it's kind of cool here
you're you've got like a set character
for whatever class it is and I kind of
like that a little bit having more like
a direction for kind of the aesthetic oh
my goodness you could choose your
horoscope all right we'll get to that
point I don't make a big believer
there's a lot to do before you go in
there's something that I really liked
that wasn't there when I first started
playing it's the beauty album so if
you're person who's kind of like me
who's not great at creating your press
r1 really quick and then are two months
so they have the system where you can
actually take characters that other
people have made if you're not like
creatively inclined like me again and
kind of use things to build off there's
there's one that looks like like a good
old Witcher in there and you can
actually take these characters that
people have made apply it to what you're
doing and then kind of build off from
that or just take someone's character
entirely why not right it's here in the
gallery anyways these hop ranking ones
yeah there we go so that's a cool option
for you if if you want to kind of have a
jumping-off point but we're gonna make
some one yeah let's make its holy new
character honestly like character
customization is a huge thing for me
when playing a game and I could spend
hours and hours on
we'll try not to spend that long but I
do if you look through everything you
you have to live the one of the big
things about black desert is its it's
very high high quality like action
combat which I'm very into and also just
the fact that you literally can spend
hours upon hours in making just the
perfect character for yourself the
changes made to the head appearance will
be reset
I'll take care of that while you check
out what here you have interesting
honestly maybe I should switch the one
I'm wearing first oh I can because you
see this fur cuff around his head so if
you want to change what what gear you
have on if you actually go in like out
of here and then into action you can
change different previews for your you
got like three high level sets and then
kind of like you're leveling sets you
probably don't want to have the helmet
on okay okay now we're good oh ding if
you want the pure customization shot
it's it's all there for you yeah oh I
think these three cuz I know there's a
few different versions of this game that
you can purchase and some of them come
with some extra items and extra goodies
so I think these first three are all a
part of that actually so let's see this
one looks a nickel I kind of like this
one hmm
let's go with the red this one looks
looks nice spin them around a little bit
look at those axes yeah I'm very excited
to start swinging those arounds zoom a
little they get the full view
I don't even walk with those on alright
alright I think you got to have a strong
back strong strong man okay I get to
pick my my stance a little bit of
preview of the oh there's great he's
bowing I'm gonna pray there we go
cool alright so in terms of stances Oh
got the esports pose I got a perfect for
its pose it's perfect okay now we can
change the appearance but I can actually
see the hair what's going on up here
needs a brush that's what we definitely
need oh oh oh that might be the winner
actually you changed the shape of the
hair it's you interesting I don't know
if I would want it to be shorter
I think extra big fro is great curls
strings and curl level oh yeah that the
hair sliders are a lot this is great you
could there's almost too much to
customize I know so many options oh wait
I can actually can't see the difference
well not let me see it unless they back
up maybe you just can't curl the fro the
fro is too strong but PS were already
had this game a little bit ago it just
came out today right I think it was
actually there was some pre-order bonus
time yeah pre-order you could preload it
and get it ready I got a chance to play
a little bit this morning just to kind
of see how the other controls work
because again I only really played on
the PC there you go you get my girl so
you can mess with all like you got your
main hair color your highlights and then
the shine so you can get crazy with it
no this is awesome oh he's so pretty and
a third color yeah
yeah sure why not look how are you guys
yeah these aren't some intense options
here I like I like this kind of like
kind of like light pink out to its dark
purple that's really good this is going
a direction I wasn't expecting but I
like it
start playing see this is an important
part of playing exactly this is play
this is our character we're going to
spend time with and we've got to make
sure that they are making the statement
that they're making it's sending a
message it's letting people know that
we're not just here this is great to
grind it out but we're also here it's a
party
oh I actually need the beard to be the
same color there we go moustache layers
this is the stache gotcha
I don't know I feel like I need he needs
a giant purple stache to go with this I
kind of like that there's crazy colors
and stuff too because it doesn't really
seem like the type of game where you
know it's generally very like colorful
in terms of like the stuff you're gonna
wear in something like that but bright
purple air I think I'm about it oh yeah
look at that mustache now it's getting
real yeah yeah oh bring it together
everything's starting to make sense now
I think yeah the purple the Purple's
words on it
I still can't I don't know if there's
been like a character creator that's as
in-depth as this games is over the
course of time that it's been out at
least I can't think of long matches bro
this bike you like maybe that one oh all
right I like that one it matches it
matches the fro don't even remember
which colors is that looks was good
looks good the best thing about this
setup that we're getting right now is
that we'll be very easy to spot yeah
it's kind of like a target at the same
time okay I like that one okay I see
some other oh yeah there we go there you
go
it's gonna bring that in line then we
got to get the the sideburns there we go
just the biggest sideburns you've ever
seen this man's got a lot of a lot of
hair it's great it's gonna fit the
berserk style we're going for I like it
that's kind of cool I'm officially
having too much fun and we have an
answer
two hours later so customizing your
character that's okay I mean it takes
time and precision
oh the brows I like the little icon with
the eyebrow brush - yeah amazing touch
you know we got to get these massive
massive spiky eyebrows
that deep person so intense I kind of
like the lighter colored eyebrows they
have the lighter color and it would
attract more attention to his eyes this
is a very pure shade of pink I like it
all right so let me just make sure nice
all the links are at 100% that's what we
went face tight he looks a bit happier
there well that one he has a little
smirk yeah it's gonna enjoy that's very
serious look I think I like the semi
happy don't you looks like he's going in
for like a smooch okay colors options
for days literally everything cool oh
dang man we should absolutely said some
super bright like pink or something make
it more shiny how's sweaty oh the
perspiration it's very serious there we
go a hundred percent perspiration all
the time yeah that was kind of kind of a
color to match think this do we have a
breakdown of the different like we do we
do and we have that handy if your
interests
there you go because there's three
different versions actually any a bunch
of cool stuff yeah yeah like some of the
the pearls to get some cool outfits if
you need doing stuff so you got standard
deluxe and ultimate don't I don't see
that the prices on here but you get some
some extra bonuses in there I think the
standard one might be thirty bucks if
I'm standard one is thirty dollars and
it kind of goes up from there all the
way up to the ultimate which costs you
50 not 100 so 100 but gets you so much
extra stuff I guess right so standard
and then deluxe and then ultimate
caspere's Casper's taking the characters
[ __ ]
yes thank you I appreciate that I am
also taking the character I like those
super sweaty because I feel like that's
gonna be needed it's such a a good just
option to have an option I didn't even
realize I wanted oh my goodness girl
he's so [ __ ] this is where you can
actually mess with like the the actual
you can put down their hair for like if
they're wearing a hat or whatever but
you can actually adjust through like the
the meters or if you press I think l1
it'll actually let you physically grab
different parts of the face to move
around so you can actually like not just
do it through a meter but also oh I want
to move his forehead up you can
physically like grab it and move it up
and look at each little part of the face
you can actually so I was like forehead
man like bet all the nose the nose the
mouth so I appreciate that they have
like the the different ways of kind of
going about customizing the character
too so it's not just all moving a slider
left and right oh okay
imagine waking up to seeing this guy I
I'd be scared not gonna lie I would feel
like this guy knows how to party oh he
definitely knows how to party
right if I woke up and just saw him
standing in front of me like do it what
it's like his forehead 8 a.m. this is
wild I cannot wait to see how many
different things we got into the main oh
I feel like I need to come back to the
shape after I finish everything else
although I just messed up his forehead
some crazy that's a feature you know
that's that's fine
density alright I already know he's
about to be so fabulous movie ass is it
easier to play on the controller
keyboard I've only played a little bit
on the controller earlier today but
there's something kind of like playing
an action MMO on a controller that feels
kind of good I still love my mouse and
keyboard controller but I'm surprised by
how well the controller works I think I
like the black eyeliner oh yeah that's
deep so intently yeah cool
see you bye I think the sounds kind of
cool rugged he's a bruiser acara so it
looks like it looks like a berserker put
them like that's that one yeah yeah yeah
I agree the eyes left I am always
different pupils give him some cat eyes
oh man
I need different colors I'll make his
eyes real big wish I had hair like this
dude kind of see I know that I wear like
a beanie all the time but if I had hair
like this would probably give me a
reason not to wear a beanie all the time
this must be the outer part yeah you'd
like the circle ins action here you
you've you wants to know one doesn't
launch our ps4 today okay right now it's
available right now if you want to give
it a go
the servers are bumping people are
running around I didn't realize how much
changing the eyes are bring it all
together yeah what it really brought it
all together slightly more intense pink
or should we try a deep purple can you
wrote oh yeah can we get like one eye of
each oh you're gonna make some love oh
yeah it's getting you can't rotate the
camera we're taking the situation
head-on at this point I gotta look I'm
dead in the eyes by the way you guys if
you aren't enjoying all these
customisation options so far I keep in
mind that today's stream has brought to
you by black desert so I'm very thankful
because now I get to do all of this
wonky crazy stuff there was a part of me
that legitimately like when we were
getting ready to do this I I'm like up
the entire thing is just gonna be on
making a character because that's how
many freakin options there it's how it
always goes cuz you just have too much
fun making making your dude and then
you're like whoa is this not on game yes
Nicholas it is online as heck it is
massively oh yeah we can't even start
thinking about a name yet we've got too
much stuff in the way before you know
honestly chat you need to start helping
a scene you don't think of it right now
so that by the time we do fand i think
i'm going with this i like it it's got
kind of like a
oh man even more dude is a Jojo villain
now HECO oh cool okay now this is really
going somewhere here got it
this is great I'm I'm just when we get
to the tattoos will probably also make a
big difference because I think you might
be able to color the tattoos I love this
one okay but we need to make it like is
it an MMO yes it is to kind of give you
the idea of what what black desert is if
you if you haven't seen it or heard of
it it's it's an action MMO RPG that has
a different style of progression than
like a like a classic MMO I guess but
the strongest point of it is that it has
the action combat that scholarly is cool
like button combinations and combos that
you can do there's a lot of movement
involved they do a really good job I
think my favorite part of it outside of
just how reactionary it all is is I
really like the the camera effects
because they really sell like the
impacts and that it's such a small
little thing that definitely helps make
the combat feel that much more intense
has always kind of been my favorite
thing about black desert which is why I
keep kind of coming back to it wonky and
I love it
think the eyes are where I need them to
be oh my I didn't even pay attention
what you were doing he's got like a it's
like crack oh I'm having too much fun at
this I lot I line there you go is some
eyeliner I really did I line I don't
know if we could be able to see the
eyeliner through what you got going on
here oh I see I was like I don't even
know what this means part of the screen
is action combat the one after this yes
indeed okay so oh dang look at these dad
well he's got he's got a good Wolverine
energy
our case is mentioning if I feel it name
him Monday morning I wish I looked as
good on a Monday I don't even know where
this tattoo is no it's coz the density
is really low okay let's turn it up you
turn up yeah there you go
oh dang okay so now start seeing what it
is scary skulls ooh okay and that one
might be the winner that one on the
bottom is even scary in the preview oh
this one yeah that one certain different
colors no yeah that one's too much for
me too
I like this one though actually yeah
that's good that's that's that's anime
as hell
who the purple
I'm kind of digging the purple here yeah
the purple purple brings you know cuz
you've got the contrast against the pink
eyebrows wrinkles returnable he's gonna
be old as heck let's go look he's sweaty
and purple all right what do we got as
some name ideas in the chat so far a
sparkle heart I enjoy that already
something about know what don't make him
proud yeah yeah he enjoys his work yeah
standby expression so this is the the
face that he uses this is gonna be your
the next one the face that he's gonna
have in the game and I don't know the
the fact that the the weight of the
expressions turned up all the way at the
start I kind of like the I'm a savage
land yeah that looks like he's ready to
just let me see what it's like when oh
he's like less savage less savage you'll
bring him down calm him down a bit
yeah yeah I'm still a little angry yeah
make him a little angry but not quite as
angry as all right all right this is
looking fantastic here these marks on
his skin is that just a part of who I
think it is yeah okay so now we're gonna
go back to faith shape but honestly
there's only one part I really want to
change I just want his chin to be
massive I think that was just a part of
an actual thesis thing I had to make all
right you know I'm skull crusher I
really like this all right what crime
suggestion just name Emma Ryan here we
go yeah we got some some some body
shapes a month you gotta turn the muscle
all the way up this dudes he's ripped
shredded yeah exactly we're gonna make
them extremely tall oh heck yeah my
goodness
very wyatt there you go there you go
okay oh this is really getting berserk
you're like here I've got the individual
parts that we can adjust yeah let's get
these shoulders I want to make sure oh I
guess I don't know
so square and L Square and all the
change the size I like how it also you
can you can attach it so it's
symmetrical name I'm Craig Cecil land
camp I'm gonna submit Lancaster as I
like Lancaster Oh men Savage Steve it's
character creation the true endgame see
it's character creation and then it's
getting your your fashion down cuz like
that that fashion bit is definitely a
big part of an overall log like we can
just run around like this but that's
only half the puzzle oh my god I service
all sorts of things he's got a powerful
look yeah I'm enjoying this
alright the hands yeah I was like we
need to give extremely big hands okay
big hands make sure you can grab all
those muscle part well you know this
person he's a bruiser always rib joints
honestly
where's part two gonna take yeah where's
bright dude
Nicholas wants to know is this game free
to play it's not free to play but
there's no monthly subscription when you
buy it name which is kind of cool I
really like the the idea of being able
to just buy a game and be able to play
it whenever home Jeff super ribs except
part ones muscles are just really oddly
defined so he's gonna be a little flabby
chested there you go alright more
tattoos you already know there you go
good luck getting good name we'll find
some good work honestly we've got some
time I like this I name him Doug Doug
funnie Doug would I love it
mr. pickles also a good name also a good
place to go get sandwiches big that
contrasts I like it okay I still can't
get over just how how sweaty boy it's
just such a sweaty sweaty boy edit pose
so you can also cuz you can also take
pictures and upload them to the gallery
you can pose the character out the
twist-action don't really do too much
all right what else we got here did the
body they hair the voice the voice is
very important so his voice obviously
needs to be as deep as possible because
that's just like like Vin Diesel status
oh my god hello woman one more time
no the first one was like what that
Aaron is that's what we need to keep it
on for sure yeah that's the best one all
right all right there we go that's our
guy let's see the camera in our three
there we go bring it out a bit get a
whole hole shot of the entire picture
here yeah I like it we didn't change our
horse come here
okay so horoscope definitely not what I
was picturing when I hope what I was
gonna open it up oh okay okay
the camera giant would be the the best
Canon choice
exactly enjoys art optimistic free Oh
water I think he definitely likes art
and he's optimistic you free giant
dragon tree insensitive sociable you
know give him that wagon horn just
selfish dang definitely precious very
precious I'm [ __ ] I'm feeling the boat
I like the idea of this this this
Berserker being like yeah don't judge a
book by it's cover
yeah okay so okay now that I've created
the hair I kind of want to go back and
just take another look at look at where
we're at cuz I might go back to the
first choice which was also a furry one
we have our own okay so I think you'll
be like that one or something you know
what I'm gonna go back to the original
one that they started this with alright
I think I think we're good to pick a
name and get out of some some heads up
honestly this looks pretty good yeah I'm
down with him seven uh he's having a
good time
nice
all right we've done it so I think you
press square and then it'll take us to
the name name creation guys moment of
truth here I'll let you do the honors in
the naming ceremony Felix says he's
definitely a Cecil I've been I've been
playing a lot of jock is a three and I
kinda just wanna like house wants to
hear you I know it's not gonna work or
will it take me in let's do this yes
doesn't fit on the street should I name
to merit a what am I think oh my god
that was a missed opportunity what are
we doing I can't believe this okay so
not only was his intro little screenshot
epic as heck I'm excited to see him in
action talking about more classes so
that's all detailed in the roadmap
because they've got they announced the
roadmap at Gamescom for how the contents
gonna be rolling out you've got
awakenings new classes new regions
basically they've got they've got plans
for where this is they've got some plans
so anything that kind of isn't here
right now is on the way phoo crazy cure
you
Craig the Conqueror Craig the Conqueror
that's a good one too crock would have
been great to spend the whole time
searching for a lover
[Music]
yeah so I haven't played too much in
this class so this is gonna be a bit of
a learning experience for me yeah
because all the classes are pretty
different we got some story going on
some story that don't seem to be here
yeah oh dang it can't be is that you
will just do the voice acting sorry but
you shouldn't you should have known
better
so this is your your little like ghost
creature that follows you around and
kind of helps you with stuff my feeling
okay I'm so big it's wonderful he is
Marta beauty my leg is as big as
literally anyone around oh my goodness
so great I love that my character's name
is qu Plissken all right
we start our adventure except this
quests
first I'm just a little bit
cool he's so fast forgive you faster you
can't sprint too I would be pretty
scared if here you was running out
you're finally awake today I can barely
contain my excitement same my dude for
those of you asking how much this game
is the standard edition is 30 bucks and
it's available now on ps4 just drop
there's also a deluxe edition and an
ultimate edition deluxe is going to be
50 and ultimate is going to be a hundred
and each version comes with a bunch of
different awesome things so we've gotta
go kill gray fox oh snap gray fox you'd
better be shook right now there we go
grey fox is much healthier blast
cool I I do really appreciate how easy
it is to kind of move through the UI to
accept classes and stuff like I'm
already just okay this is very different
from playing the Archer imagine you're
just in this field and so I I definitely
just pick that thing up and tossed it
yep okay you should have been playing
one of these I know you've been exposed
but Archer wasn't even in the thing it's
always bad
Phil manator at us says I'm scared to
get this game because I heard the crane
is ridiculous how do you feel about the
grind in this game is it a bit on the
side but that's something that I kind of
liked about it yeah that kind of seems
like a default for a most MMORPG right
you just have to be prepared for that
grind I think that the grinding is
alleviated though because the combat is
I say as I am another wolf crime said Oh
literally a gray fox honestly I thought
it was a person to you like oh we gotta
go probably probably could have
elaborated on that a little bit more but
sorry I just got excited part so then
showing us our quest tracker we've got a
quest from a black spear Oh
[Music]
their whole clan I tried to like how
brute and savage he is like his attacks
are literally using his shoulder and his
body and lunges the axes his face is
blocked up by Oh get on the ground and
just kind of like walk it out oh wait I
can come on I can just prone walk oh my
quicker oh man okay I'm gonna just stop
messing around here I got important
things to do important people to see
hamaji ma is the crazy when I shouldn't
even imagine
head down to the ancient stone chamber
so another thing that's kind of nice
about this is like say you got a you got
a go like to the bathroom or something
you you can actually hit like Auto walk
and it'll it'll auto path to the next
quest that you have chosen like you can
go and like get a drink or whatever I
can pick up your quest wherever you left
off you don't lose any time easy peasy
fishing when hey yeah you gotta walk
before you can crawl you gotta crawl
before you can walk and then you get the
fishing exactly cuz honestly a huge
thing about this game is the life skills
as well
I really like how the combat is though
in this game so far compared to other
you know other RPGs and stuff like that
which are like you know you walk on
stuff but this one is like testing your
ability also as a gamer right it's more
of like a three-room yeah active combat
system so yeah I like that I would
imagine you know being a ranger and
stuff that's where your skill really
comes in handy yeah they have a lot of
really cool like like you can backflip
and jump around and kind of like do
stuff off of that let me check on this
artifact it is ancient after all energy
emanating from the artifact okay
sir the our spirit friend in this
artifact are probably tied together you
got I'll check this out
I carefully just won't stop swinging
quick get him out of here Oh No
I've been had huge faces tired
he's a berserker tell us to stay away oh
dang
unstable what would give you that idea
could it be the hair it's just a phase
Oh they've gone up inside of the giant
block and they're they're doing
something threatening I think time
stopped
Oh ting this is not I'm not here for
whatever dangers about I was just
outside throwing a bunch of wolves
around now he's leveled up he's cool
he's adorable but he also sounds really
evil yeah
teller I ain't forgetting how big I am
yeah every time it comes back like oh
I'm a massive so something pretty cool
about the combat system in this game
that I'm actually really interested in
learning more about is that there is
kind of like a combo system like
fighting games and certain moves you can
actually cancel into other moves and so
it really does seem like you know the
combat is kind of up to you like what
can you create what kind of combos can
you do and will turbo mode here room I
know he's running really fast it's gonna
hold up for a second I guess yeah
they're like certain attacks change into
other attacks and you can actually get
access to different moves if you do like
uh like a shoulder charge into your main
attack will do a different thing from
just like a regular I like games that go
that route I mean obviously I love
fighting games but there's you know
somebody games I follow kind of that
same theme but
oh yeah like the fool to hit act spin
into the charge when different
directions will call different already
level four gonna back attack on them
yeah I should play more of this it's
very fun yeah like seeing clips really
fun obviously we just started this
character but some of the other
abilities in this class and are
definitely super cool super savage
looking and that's just one class
there's so many other classes available
- well that's not another thing - I I
think it popped up earlier but the more
you you go and attack a certain type of
[Music]
but the more your understanding of them
kind of goes up so your eye can start
off not being able to tell how weak
something is until you understand like
okay this is what it is and then you'll
start seeing like itself because great
we don't see
oh so it really is all about learning
yeah knowledge is power
exactly well though because that kind of
adds another element for the grind right
you want to become where were these
enemies can unlock that ability
our battle understanding is PC so now we
can actually see yeah
[Music]
and I'm assuming that pertains to each
like enemy you fight like once you run
into a new enemy you got to do it all
over again that's cool a little bit more
of an incentive the grind through
certain elements
we are making our way through these
quests and honestly you guys if you're
completely new to the game then the
quests are gonna be your best choice and
kind of learning more about the game
getting through the story becoming more
familiar with the mechanics and
everything to do before you kind of go
off and venture onto your own so if
you're you know feeling like you don't
know where to start when you pick this
game up and start with quests start with
the main story quests and go from there
it would be a huge help
crime says why black desert it looks
more like a green forest yeah well I
don't think we've gotten actually to the
desert part itself but if I recall
correctly the desert is in between two
like battling nations pretty much we're
kind of fighting for the black desert
because it's got some valuable resources
so you know they haven't gotten to the
black desert portion of it just yet
we're still just a young a young giant
soul so make a learn about the immature
tree spirits oh dang gotta go get our
tree murder on
I throw the tree walking my attacks I
know this tree is fighting back I'm a
bee rank for the immature tree spirits
we gotta help them mature by chopping
them down
it's the perfect class for this club up
and down should be on two axes so I
realize that I probably just doing the
fight should be the Hulk ah see these
these are the things you probably could
make a really good Hulk in here - oh I
got it I got other ones all groups
cousins yeah I carry on over here he's
just covered in tree blood so a real a
real mess for him
and for those of you just tuning in
today's stream is brought to you by
black desert and black desert is
available today on ps4 just drop today
on ps4 so for those of you familiar with
the game you now have another way to
play for those of you have never heard
of it now it's an amazing time to get
into it because there's also gonna be a
lot of great things on the way for this
game but obviously just a ton to bite
into if you've never played just off
release so check that out we also are
going to be giving you an opportunity to
get the game for free because we have a
couple of codes for black desert to give
away and we got a good amount
so stay tuned for that we are going to
put the code onto the stream there's
gonna be one character missing from the
code that you'll have to get but first
come first serve on who's gonna get that
so in just a moment we are going to give
away our first code so stay tuned it is
gonna be for ps4 so make sure you have
PS one I'm gonna give you guys a few
minutes get your paper and pens ready
off as well so you can start writing it
down is this a monthly payment game no
so that's the one of the coolest things
about it I think is that you buy the
game once and you have it so if you get
one of these codes you can come back and
play this game any time exactly so who's
ready who's ready to try to acquire a
code right now it is going up
immediately right there on your screen
bottom left you'll see one character
missing this is just to make it a little
fun for you guys but first come first
serve the code is right there bottom
left your screen right above our camera
and this is for ps4 you're gonna also
like crimes as in the chat go to PSN
online on a website and you can also
enter the codes there if you do redeem
it call it out somebody we know
you got it we will leave this out for a
few moments while you guys try to snag
it oh man there is a lot going on what's
even better is that everyone else is
also doing this cause for you to see all
these people or school Wizards I'm
seeing a ton of like wizards
I saw a couple Rangers maybe one Ranger
I'm surprised we're not seeing more
berserks out and about there aren't a
lot of berserkers that stick out like
drew you does sure use definitely one of
a kind he's great it makes me love him
even more so he's a good character I'm
into him
all right on the road again heading into
town we do have a missing character in
the code but maybe in a few minutes if
no one says they claim it we might give
you some clues as to what that missing
character is but please let us know if
you've redeemed it we also have two more
coats giveaway this stream so no worries
there
commander cliff the code is for black
desert on ps4 so here's your chance to
get this game for buried story time
oh yeah - doesn't sound too bad I think
I think yeah here's a beef basic
etiquette busy coming up with a strategy
I just wanted to talk to you he's busy
right now
spectrum of knowledge is growing his
hands I didn't even realize I made his
hands a massive but I just love it
oh it's good he can definitely grab the
the axes they're like - like frying pans
just great he's perfect yeah I love it
more and more
alright that any lucky winner redeemed
this code there's no link the code is on
the screen right now bottom left right
above our camera muscles there for the
captain no I'm so toned a good one hey
that's a good reason yeah you gotta
breathe
all right meet the Western guard camp
over here so we're just meeting all the
people in this first town I'm into it
here you this is bad soldiers are
getting injured out there only you can
save them we know we're the best take
the healing thing helmet
cool cool got our next quest lined up
already ready to head out see here I'm
pretty sure we've got some like skills
wait hold on it's like a cool like
layout showing me how to do the short oh
yeah I like gonna learn it absolutely
sign me up so we can act can we preview
all these like this more terrifying if
you think about giant who knows how to
evade yeah I see this is also new cuz
they didn't have like a cool like layout
to let you see what what you can learn
oh my gosh I'm sorry I'm kind of skate
caught up in this got Boulder crashes oh
man look at them moving on as fro this
do like an elbow drop bottom like why
not
oh nice an overhead smash okay all right
fantastic we'll get back to grinding so
I can get new stuff right we need all of
these abilities
who wants to fight you want to fight Oh
new ability I like it alright the code
has been redeemed congratulations you
guys will have another coat up very very
soon it'll be great pick this guy up -
why not
give them that headbutt alright you guys
since you're all awesome I think the
question work the missing character
should we continue that good we solve a
lot of code to giveaway I'm down for
whatever yeah you know what let's see
who has the fastest texting fingers in
the lens there you go no more hitting
character next codes coming right up you
guys so let the strong survive boom
there we go there's the next code plain
as day um if you would like to get your
hands on a copy of black desert which is
what we're playing right now then here's
your chance code is up on the screen
first-come first-serve
oh and let us help you if you got just
mash out that step miss Bonnie she's
back welcome back welcome back
I love seeing our familiar faces our
returning people Oh Mort all folks
look at this guy oh you're quite good
you're John right I am this code is
indeed for ps4 so get ready mix it one
hidden one not yeah that sounds like a
good plan crime let us know you guys so
if you try to redeem it and it's already
been redeemed aside then that means
someone got to it before you did oh it's
gone dang that was fast I know you guys
are really really on top of it now in a
few seconds we're gonna give away
another one but please guys in all of
your love and affection towards black
desert because they are sponsoring this
stream today and they're the ones
helping us get you some free codes for
this game as well so thank you so much
black desert and everyone tuning in for
hanging out with us and enjoying some of
this beautiful game
all I hear is just savagery and like
bass from each hit it's pretty good and
one is hekia oh nice
Gonzalo Mendez he is the one who rich
Riva code
Congrats thanks for also coming to the
John letting us go that's awesome you
know what I'm ready to give away another
one this is too fun this is too fun
we're doing it again super cold yeah
next code inbounds and I like it better
that we're not hating you guys ready
it's going live right now there's an
Xcode for ps4 on the screen right now
who is the fastest typer we still have a
few more off
which is really fun so do your thing
guys make it happen and let us know if
you redeem it because then we can move
on to another card I also love our voice
choice this is a rule it's got a whole
thing going for them
Jack still he crushed a beetle I guess
and increased my knowledge of how to
kill them so that's things are looking
up
yeah we're learning things we are
learning things I mean the I thought
part of the life skills right learning
stuff also like life skills are very
very important in this game sure you're
you know keeping up with everything
oh god already these guys are so fast so
fast all right that second codes been
playing easy-peasy
that was really really fast actually all
right I'm gonna give you guys like five
more minutes to get your platforms ready
so you can start typing it in the next
one oh that's how I get my dog John oh
nice that's gonna be useful
this guy's got armed rare but I don't
know well I'm gonna cause friends over
you to put everyone
all these guys we've cleared 11 out of
20 promises these aren't even ones I
need for the question today oh here just
like now I just need to satiate my need
super blonde yeah I think when we get a
chance we should show off some of these
life skills because I personally would
like to go fishing or something of this
sort well there's a lot of different
life skills you can learn there's
gathering wood cutting fishing so we'll
try to snag some of that while you can
Raphael says I just joined the stream
what are the codes for well let me tell
you the codes are for a copy of Oh black
desert on ps4 we still have some more
codes to give away so stay tuned and
obviously these codes are courtesy of
black desert which is also he's
sponsoring our stream today so much less
of it I'm gonna be putting another code
up on the screen very shortly I might
have made it we're bleeding your health
regenerates over time we're using pokey
we've got enough life now back to the
side of the tree
oh I mean these guys coming over to help
nice he's also a savage I mean a brazier
cricket I just call him a savage it just
looks like a savage all right who's
ready for the next code you guys get
those typing fingers ready because here
we go see you won all right the next
code is up on the screen grab it while
you can
and if you're the one who redeems it let
us know that you wanted it done it again
are you calm down
oh dang two more one more
get out of here on the ground there we
go still gonna find a dented helmet I
mean I feel like you just made like a
hundred of them call up our ghost pal
see what's going on so a few things to
mention for people wondering is that
there are some useful camera settings
because obviously we have a lot of
action going on there's camera shake but
sometimes people don't really like that
effect too much you can adjust these
settings in the menu in the general
settings menu you can also zoom in and
zoom out which can be useful for looking
around and you can toggle chat which is
something that I think we should
probably do um you can use it from the
ring menu hold l2 and right on the d-pad
for to toggle chat right on the d-pad
but I did get a whole bunch of gear
equipped all right what's the word on
this code you guys has it been redeemed
is it available still x2 2l in five in
em9 7e is this the
but definitely want that 100% oh yeah
you can also get like workers and stuff
to farm for you kinda like if you need
some resources you can pay a worker to
find it for you which is which assists
in the grind because I know a lot of
people are talking about the grind
everywhere get some help you know help
the economy and create jobs it's gone oh
snap you are fast guys got it yes you're
gonna redeem the code on your ps4 if you
go to redeem code in the PS store or you
can also go online on the website or the
app and redeem the code and then
download it onto your console later if
you think like you know typing on your
phone or typing on the keyboard any
faster then you can try that option also
yeah let me see how many more codes all
right we have three more coats to give
away you guys three more opportunities
for you to be playing black desert today
because it drops on ps4 to date jump in
and hang out with good boy here you yeah
undyne got the code congrats Undine heck
yeah
Oh JK crying what the heck man some more
those health potions cuz you know your
boy oh I'm dying doesn't have to be as
far but he does have the game on xbox
and pc okay
fair enough alright now that we're down
to our last three codes I'm gonna space
them out a little better than I did with
the first three I just got excited I
wanted to give all the codes away but
it's all good it's all good crime as
long as someone redeem the code that's
all weekend Wow they they got got before
I could actually give it a can you write
the word so you can't get horses I think
I don't like here you would just need a
massive forest what is this game afraid
so much about it we are playing black
desert yeah MMORPG it's been out for a
while but it just dropped today on ps4
so now everyone gets to join in on the
black desert action
we've got I got a lot of things to kill
in here yeah you have to defeat fifty
steel imps took us a while to get the 20
down last time
so did we got this room knocked out but
it didn't help us get to level 11 all
right so it's pretty good
getting skill points all over the place
lipstick says how did you manage to get
past the character customization I would
have been stuck there for hours
honestly I know we had work to do on the
stream to show off the rest of the game
so I had to reel myself in to not spend
at least 20 hours creating my character
although I think we did a really good
job over here oh he looks amazing he's
definitely a beast that's why I was like
I I don't know if I can handle two and
both of those things
yes our character is indeed a big boy
soulful tone that was the objective once
we started and it started snowballing I
like he just has to be the licensee yeah
you have to
all right you know what you guys enough
time is passed I'm ready to give away
another code and who's ready oh okay I'm
gonna do something fun hmm I'm putting a
question mark over the final character
let me give you a clue about of what the
character is all right so the code is up
this code is for a copy of black desert
on ps4 and the hint behind the final
character on this code is it's what you
type in to pay respects there you go go
it's a gimme that is that yes I just
handed that to you on a silver platter
you guys so there you go
the final mystery character is what you
press to pay respects so let me know you
guys let me know if you try to redeem it
and it's not available because then that
means it's been redeemed already that's
why it's all done I really like the fact
that you can grab individual people
around with yeah I would be disappointed
if you couldn't that seems like a really
really fitting move for this class how
much is this game ask Stevie it is 30
bucks for the standard edition 50 bucks
for the deluxe edition and 100 for the
ultimate edition each Edition comes with
different items
you know tools that can help you when
you're playing in terms of you know
utility and also some cosmetic items
there's also some real pets that you can
add to your character that comes with
certain tiers like Ultimate Edition you
get two pets you get snow wolf dog and
the junii cat so a lot of cool stuff
available if you're interested in
getting a better Edition someone got too
angry oh yeah someone asked earlier in
the chat about PvP but there is PvP in
this team there's open world PvP that's
unlocked at level 50 after completing
the level up quest this is probably go
quicker if I join a group somebody China
[Music]
right what's the word on this code you
guys who's redeemed it who's the lucky
winner secret area where they're coming
out of on their base
understanding of fighting stealing's has
gone up there's getting more and more
efficient
I just noticed he had some like you know
tassels at the end of his axes
I wonder bingling swing them around
there you go
axe nunchucks she's trying to cast it
frost Bella just smack them into the
ground here one go get a horse you go
buy a horse at the stable I am dying to
see our character riding her horse I
just know it's gonna look at the fan and
I'm gonna love everything about it
if the horse scales to the air that
would be awesome we would have a massive
world the biggest horse
are the classes gender locked yes and
each class has like an awakened version
of itself also which I'm curious to see
everyone's awake and seen on the website
if you guys want to check it out and go
to councils play black desert calm has a
bunch of really really useful
information but it also shows off all
the classes too so like it's the archer
ninja a ton of stuff actually yeah good
boy Berserker so the the best thing
about that is especially now with the
game coming out on ps4 is that's where
you can find the road map and when all
the contents go with the other classes
in the awakens
and when you can expect them to show up
cruising here are you 32 of these guys
killed oh yeah
what's the word on this code who's got
the code up on the screen to k76 ABN
cake xlm with a mystery character in
which the clue is you press this button
to tear aspects I need confirmation that
someone just received this so we can
give away the other ones you guys
yeah the archer class is male the Ranger
class is do procedure you throw a guy on
the ground yeah impacts the shear force
is too much it's so strong here you too
strong congratulations says whoever it's
nag to the code but don't worry we
didn't get one cuz we've got another one
right away
yes I'll shoot right now I'm gonna see
the final code for the last five minutes
mystery but bad ethics we're giving it
away it's burning a hole in my pocket I
need to give it away
yeah
alright next code is going live no
mystery characters on this one I'll save
a mystery character for the final code
here we go get prepared there it is
PPP PPP test your might redeem the code
combos though talk to our ghost pal
what's going on go kill some imp wizards
considerably less on the outside have
any skills I could get the boulder crash
it's pretty good did the code get
redeemed already that was a quick one
that was a quick one Eleazar says I give
up with the codes no don't give up we
still have one more
we still have one more I will post that
up in five minutes big angry boys over
here yeah they are upset I hear lots of
growling and grunting oh it really is a
satisfying throw the impacts everything
feels like it does make a difference it
makes it feel more impactful
okay knock him off
it's not even that bottom is drop that's
jump in attack
is this giant on your side or is that a
bad guy here another family a bad guy oh
yeah you said you haven't hit you yet
autumn to fight me bring it down
but yeah you guys in terms of the
classes you can view them all on the
website console that play black desert
calm not all of them are available on
ps4 just yet but they have the road map
available and a lot of stuff on the ways
so you still have a lot to get through
just off the base game as is and there's
stuff to look forward to so now's a
really good time to pick it up just drop
today on ps4 and GameSpot live today was
brought to you by black desert so thank
you black does it for that and for
cooking it up with all of these codes we
saw well more code to give away before
the end of the stream so make sure
you're prepared for that one more shot
to put the sweet beat down
it's just chaos yes this point where
everyone's out right now it's just
bring that back attack down attacks now
you're gonna get a chance to get up
cyborg man asked what's the code for the
code is for a copy of black desert
that's what we're playing today a copy
of this on ps4 but free so stay tuned
because in a few minutes they're gonna
be giving away the final code
here
the authorities brilliant
oh my gosh second hey we have in there
yeah okay this is curious true element
this is where he belongs
for wizard Trinity stab something with a
knife
chat says you should level up your
skills maybe that'll help you slice
through these steel stainles so then
I've been going into my skills every now
and then and I've been I've been staying
up on top of the most part
we did unlock some new ones which were
pretty useful already in our combos I'm
still super stoked about like the fact
that there's that
combo system element oh yeah and give me
the people's elbow yeah I did it there
oh we miss I love it I got a bag attack
on it totally counts
this is the Berserker class for those of
you asking in the chat I think right now
there's warrior Ranger sorceress
Berserker wizard which and then classes
to look forward to we're gonna be the
archer ninja Cylon Dark Knight striker
and if you go on the website they do to
break down each class kind of their main
weapons their sub weapons what attack
type that they use best situations for
them and then it even goes into detail
about their a weakened self which is
also really cool to me I'll get like an
upgraded look and whatnot so definitely
check that out lots of useful
information is it time yes it's time to
give away the last code don't shoot I am
ready so here we go the final code I was
thinking about hiding another character
on this one but I'm kind of just want to
give it away what do you think all right
are you guys ready the final code for a
free digital copy of a black desert on
ps4 is going up right now I have to make
sound effects it's very important so
there it is this is the last chance to
get a free copy of black deserts for ps4
which just dropped today for those of
you wondering I love that he's all
sketched out
he's not having a good time what's a
boss fight Oh ding I'm ready four
minutes for a boss fight sounds like a
plan let's do it hit it
all these steel imps we just body your
whole clan you don't even want to mess
with me there oh hey
got some people over here waiting for it
right take a dark portal oh no no it's
the man oh he's just gonna crawl
straight up out of the ground well we
might have some help ray the other
people playing this mission to ask me
for Dragon Quest sound effects true
alright let's do this
it's gonna be easy got some help that's
another oh oh jokes on him I was down
before exactly got there first
oh don't even I can probably grab that
would be epic oh dang the code was
redeemed already congratulations to all
of our stream winners today that was six
code redeem the six lucky winners on
today's stream thank you guys so much
for participating and if you didn't get
a code well the game is available for 30
bucks two days
in addition on ps4 here he was a skilled
in hand combat it's only natural that
his evasion is top tier as oh man he's
like half-life what's that that's not -
oh yeah red nose that's the one we want
oh he's he's low is on lockdown
the whole time we're still doing all the
wrong
oh dang ready go he's scared oh he's
almost done born
oh dang oh wow wow that hurt a lot
[Music]
it tells me please drink a potion yeah
well you tell yourself we get to get all
of our awards we beat the the boss is no
more the land is a little bit more safe
thanks to you but look at that face
the face of a hero oh it's it's storming
now it's kind of difficult what there he
is
great there's our boy no great great
work yeah take a seat just take a load
off he'll lay down and relax all right
you guys well well here you take a nice
little rest after a hard day's work we
are going to go ahead and in the stream
there thank you so much for tuning in
today's gamespot live was brought to you
by black desert and shout out to them
for hooking us up with all of those
codes we had six lucky winner is sitting
on the stream and obviously we just had
so much fun not only in creating the
character but then watching him go out
into the world and demolish everything
really good it was really nice to kind
of get back into this game because I
didn't enjoy it when it first came out
and I kind of forgot no I'm like oh man
just a bit more exactly yeah
you know it just came out today on ps4
is don't why not yeah well thank you
guys so much for tuning in that is going
to wrap it up for the stream today but
make sure you tune in every weekday at
11 a.m. for some gamespot live action
and until next time we'll see you later
[Music]